largo for the last taping of conan on
tbs and i'm here with
conan himself big surprise who knew i
would be here
representing conan uh let me tell you a
little bit about where we are
we've been taping our shows since uh
really uh well for a while in covid like
a lot of hosts i was trapped at home
then we made our way to this theater
it's an old theater as you can tell from
this dressing room
um it's kind of uh this has
it's just really needs help
it's uh this is just crud everywhere the
first piano ever made
here wheel was invented
that's the first wheel so anyway uh it
is um but it's got a lot of charm and it
really saved us because
it gave us the feeling of being able to
go someplace and have a special home
and then the way we had planned to be
winding down the tbs
show anyway and then it just kind of
timed out in a weird way that uh
our show coming to an end this nightly
show
doing a day in day out show and late
night for 28 years
came to an end just as the pandemic
ended which is actually really sweet
because the audiences are insane they're
excited because they're our fans and our
fans are
the best in the world but then they're
also just so happy
to be out and so we're getting this nice
um
i know it's like a double wave i'm not a
surfer but it's imagine
two waves they merge and form a super
wave
that's what's happening uh that terrible
analogy but
there you go um can you tell me a little
bit about to that point
what was it like after a year of no
audiences and just cardboard cutouts
to come out for that first show what was
that like in front of people here at
largo awful
terrible no laughs the worst they were
and i was like
i want the cutouts because with the
cutouts you can imagine i'm
killing you know what i mean uh i had a
my girlfriend
senior year in high school was a cutout
and we got along great and then
suddenly real people are here with their
demands and their tastes and their
standards no it was uh really beautiful
to see people again
and it's been uh lovely um
to to be here doing it it's uh it's
absolutely been great
yeah and and the thing to do is like
it's interesting because
you know we're doing so much in terms of
the podcast and all these other things
that are happening
and it's very sweet to say goodbye to
the late night show and kind of look
forward
right to what's next looking back um i
mean on
late night the tonight show and conan on
tbs
is there anything that sticks out to you
uh of moments that are that are
uh overly special you know what i
realized that uh
someone calculated this the other day a
lot of you watching weren't born when i
was started uh being you know doing my
late
night show in uh september of 93
uh so you were lucky you missed that
but um i want to say uh
it is amazing we calculated that i've
done probably over
4 000 hours of television
um six of it quite good uh but we've
done
we've just done a lot of television and
um
i'm i i keep trying to sum it up
i'm very proud of the different types
and styles of comedy we've done we've
tried so many things
we threw everything against the wall we
did everything we could think of
uh and i'm very happy about
that um it's very hard to say what are
the highlights i mean
the highlight the thing i remember most
about the first year of late night was
not getting cancer sold
because we were supposed to get canceled
i think i was canceled at one point but
they forgot to
like submit the form um the stan
paperwork didn't go through that yeah so
just surviving in the early days
and then when the show started to uh get
whole you know catch on
and yeah uh these stars that i grew up
with um
that i saw on tv when i was a kid would
come by and you'd get to actually talk
to
these people that i'd seen when i was
sitting in a high chair and i would
meet them and yeah so that freaked me
out and then
uh i don't know i mean i can't even
begin
it's it's too much my mind explodes when
someone says
what are the highlights because imagine
you've just spent your whole life eating
really good food
what was your favorite sandwich quick
quick you can't do it yeah
so i don't know um
i think i mean the god
even i mean obviously that that last
week on the tonight show is
really memorable and i just love that we
were
in that dire situation and then we just
went uh
something snapped and we just decided to
have a lot of fun
and so we did and we did everything
um we pretended to spend nbc's money
on picassos and then and burn them and
destroy them
and people watching got really mad
because they thought we were really
doing it no
we didn't really destroy a picasso come
on
come on but people but i also sort of
loved that uh
that last episode of the tonight show
and yeah and
will ferrell doing that insane song
and all those musicians coming out so
that was a highlight somebody asks
actually somebody's asking in the chat
do you still own the taurus
yes poor taurus 1992
ford taurus uh it's a it's an emerald
green
it's got a stick shift and uh it's got a
six cylinder
engine and they call that the old
wolf in sheep's clothing because people
think oh look
that's a car for like a soccer mom
um anyway no it's still really nerdy uh
but i still have that car it's in
storage here in los angeles
and it has an old hornet's nest in the
in the trunk
and um and the clutch is still broken
from the time
brad pitt drove it on the show and we
did a stunt where he
tore he tore off on the street in
the uh taurus and um
and broke the clutch like stripped it
and so
i was such a brad pitt fan that i'm i
didn't get it fixed
because people were like you know what
this thing doesn't really shift front
it'll be like i know
brad pitt broke it because
brad pitt broke it being such a name
dropper
sometimes people wouldn't even ask and
i'd be like do you notice the clutch has
a problem
like no clutch seems fine to me don't
you think something's wrong with
it uh i don't know i mean it slips a
little in second career
that's because brad pitt busted it up
cause he's my friend uh anyway that was
cool
that's amazing i know it i gotta say
like it it's so funny because
thinking about even where we are now at
the largo
and i remember you know when we started
the conan on tvs show
instagram didn't exist right like
twitpic hadn't even bought twitter you
couldn't even post a photo
on twitter and it's been so fun to do so
much great stuff
on the web it's been really fun i mean i
have to say that one of the things that
i'm very happy about
is um we don't overthink
the technology of it all i as you can
all tell just from watching any of my
clueless gamer remotes or anything with
play
or pretty much anything i do um uh
i'm not literate about technology
but i'm surrounded by people who are
what what i do is i just try to make
funny things
and then this these really smart
talented people around me
uh you know blay and ruthie too much
credit
no but not but i have all these uh
talented people around me who say
okay here's what we know to do with it
and then they take care of it i mean
i started the podcast two and a half
years ago and all i knew is
i like talking to people i want a format
where i can
babble and go
go longer than the six seven minutes
that i can do on a late night show
and really let people see how my mind
works slash doesn't work
and really uh go for it and then it
turns out that there had been this
you know amazing um thing called the
podcast for many years that many people
have done brilliant work on and i just
thought
i just want to have fun with that and
that turned into a whole thing
by the way quick plug um he's one of my
all-time favorites i just had a
conversation
uh this is round two with bill burr
and bill burr and i uh had a
conversation that went um
it gets really insane at the end to the
point where bill burr and i were both
uh it you have to check it out that
drops as the either the kids or one kid
says
um that drops on monday this coming
monday
meet with bill burr and um listen
commit because it starts to take a
journey and then um hits this fever
pitch of madness
to boston irish guys screaming on this
crazy riff
uh that bill burr and i are still trying
to figure out we don't even know how we
got onto that but please check that out
that's really fun i will say there's and
this is not
uh in any way spoiler but the the thing
about the dogs yeah that's right
i almost threw up laughing and you know
it's amazing and the other thing too is
you know
i think one thing that's been so cool to
see and especially with
with you know you doing like live shows
here
uh for the these last few weeks has been
the response from fans
and you know it's so cool to see and in
the chat uk
philippines finland yeah we're seeing so
many people watching right now
right around the world and conan without
borders has been i mean that's something
that's started in the past since you
started this tv show
i have to tell you that you know it's
really interesting because um
again uh
there are a lot of people who might be
on this chat now
who um was it a chat what is it it's a
it's a live stream but i don't know
what things are brazil argentina they're
everywhere okay
it just looks like you're holding a
vibrator uh you look at a creep right
now um
i i just what i will say is that uh
um when we got to the tbs stage if you
had told me that we would discover
all these new things during this 11 year
period
i would say that's impossible like we
just did 17 years
and probably by most standards people
might have thought well we're done
you know but um tbs
because they gave us all this freedom i
mean i can't even begin to think of it
all but clueless gamer
uh traveling around the world um and
doing all those shows
yeah podcast podcast all of the podcasts
not just yours but like
all of the crazy podcasts we're doing
may i elaborate
yeah three questions yeah so you know
it's been it's been really
a fun it's been an amazingly fertile
time creatively and that i'm very
grateful for because
um so business can be cruel
and uh it can be really nice and it can
be cruel and i've experienced some of
both
a lot a lot of the good a little but but
what i've found that is that if you just
stick to your guns and do your thing
um and keep trying to make the product
if you just
keep focusing on trying to have fun
trying to make people laugh
and try to make something worthwhile the
rest can take care of itself
and that's been joyous i mean that's
really been joyous and
i mean the tbs era we're going to go on
and
and and do more and i really love the
travel show so i want to keep doing that
uh i have really enjoyed that and i've
made so many friends
around the world wherever i go uh
armenian people see me and they go
out
and i have all these uh you know but
it's the same thing with
uh i meet people from korea oh my god
and
they embraced me i mean during the covet
area we weren't allowed but um
you know i i'm always cool with an
embrace and um and just
you go through the list of a fan who
who's from germany uh who tried to come
see me when we were in germany
but couldn't uh uh and and
i remember i remember us being in
remember we were in that there was that
huge parade in italy with those huge
yeah yeah and we're this thing in italy
and all of this huge cheer goes up from
the crowd
and it's a ton of it was like maybe what
200 people from korea
right and they were they were part of
some like exchange program
they were in italy and so all these
italians were looking at me thinking
who is this guy why is everyone cheering
for ed sheeran's sister
and um and then suddenly uh it was
because there was a korean section
there and of course i'm always going to
have my my friends in finland
and i've been to the uk and i've done
some stuff there
um and i i got to go to oxford and speak
there
a huge honor and so
you just find that um it can sound
corny i don't mean it to but there's
just a
global community of people that like
comedy and silliness
and that just seems to cross over
everything so
i can be anywhere in the world and i'll
have someone from like sri lanka
say i really loved i like that silly
thing you do
uh and and immediately
any differences we might have are
completely erased because we both love
the same
form of idiocy yeah that's what i'm
trying to do and i can't go anywhere in
the world
in the world without people saying
what's the deal with jordan
what's the deal with jordan people have
theories there are people that think
there's a maybe he's got a tumor that's
undiagnosed
uh and some people think that he's not
from this planet
he's a visitor from another world um so
it's just
it's uh i don't know to have spent
um you know to have spent
this is going to freak some of you out
but i got started professionally in
comedy in 1985 that's whoa
how long i've been around and things
just keep getting more and more fun and
more and more interesting and they
started out pretty fun and interesting
so
um that's what keeps me
going that's what really keeps me going
yeah and i have to say you know one
thing like on a personal level
is you know your speech at the end of
the tonight show obviously
has become iconic you know work hard be
kind and
and one thing i think that you've really
instilled in myself and everyone who
works for you and everyone
really who comes into contact with you
and hopefully all of you guys who are
watching is
you have this great mantra of let's try
it
let's try it and and you know people
even who asked me about clueless gamer
i was like conan was like let's try it i
don't know let's try it and i think with
the podcast
can i just can i just change one thing
please my philosophy
really seriously is let's try it but if
it doesn't work
out blame someone else i mean if i'm
going to be honest
i really am open for trying anything but
the minute it starts to go
south i'm like i i never approved this
[ __ ] i didn't think this was
uh i this is not this was not my idea
why did you guys get me into this i am
very quick
to point a finger and distance myself
but uh no i do you know what is really
nice is that
i meet many people all the time who
say that quote back to me from the
tonight show yeah one thing i just try
to say to them is i really did
mean it i've never meant anything more
in my life i really did mean it
uh i do believe that there are no
shortcuts you do have to work hard but
um it's it is amazing what you
what you can do in life and and i i i do
think that i've been obviously
very very fortunate and i believe in
luck and i
god i've i'm a poster child for luck i
had more than my share
but um we have really nice people we
work with really nice people and
we don't tolerate being on you know mean
to each other
yeah unless it's me because i i mean
i just have to i'm too good at it right
you sign the checks you get to that
we have hours of footage of me striking
you right actually physically fighting
you and you just keep coming back from
work
but uh you were like an mma level
fighter now
because of me training dummy training
training yeah
you have like you're you're this flesh
right here on either arm
he's built up incredible strength no
nerves below the neck at this point just
no
no unnecessary really that's necessary
uh yeah
it's um it's a it's been a uh it's been
a blessing and we're on to do other
things i love to make
weird stuff so there will be more stuff
coming
i love doing the podcast uh i love um
making and trap making comedy with
people i don't know
i actually like meeting strangers people
who aren't famous and doing comedy with
them and improvising in different
countries so
there will be more we'll do more um and
if you're tired of me i understand
you can just pretend this is the end and
not
watch any other stuff i do and i would
not i would not blame you
so um you'd be you'd be doing that you'd
be doing the right thing
really that's right well again thank you
all for watching thank you
thank you for continuing to watch and
follow us everywhere of course
you're watching on youtube so if you
haven't subscribed here youtube.com
please subscribe to our newsletter to
see all the great stuff we're going to
be doing about your newsletter
yes yes by going to teamcoco.com
join we do it's uh facebook.com
conan o'brien on twitter i don't
understand instagram what's instagram
deep coco it didn't exist when we
started but now it does and it won't
exist
soon okay oh god i'm going to buy it
it couldn't cost more than 200 000 to
buy instagram could it
and then it'll be mine and of course
follow our podcast now who owns i don't
know i i it's
true story i bumped into that guy once
yeah i did i [ __ ]
at some event and i said hey mark if you
had stayed at harvard like i did instead
of dropping out you'd be where i
am now stared at me didn't get it but i
was joking
true story oh my gosh
and please of course bill burr is on
conor ryan he's a friend on monday you
got to watch
watch that what listen to it i'll act it
out for you
get it wherever you get your podcast and
there's a fan episode on thursday
and you're talking about it with a new
blender yeah and then there's a new
blender there's a whole blender line
it's going to be amazing is that a
protein powder you can buy what are you
doing all this [ __ ]
i'm telling everyone we're doing stream
conan uh without borders on hbo max
yeah buy a pontiac yeah buy a pontiac
pie
ikea kias are good i know as well
uh watch bamba sucks why bothers are
great i went out that he paid for any of
that no
no we're not i like caught on the car
martin is great
and uh be sure to watch the show tonight
with dana carvey and the finale tomorrow
with jack black
hey dana carvey one of my all-time uh
comedy heroes
uh and then tomorrow night a young
up-and-coming
struggling comic slash musician name mr
jack black will be on the show
and he better bring it cause if he
doesn't bring it
i'm gonna sick zuckerberg
uh thank you all and oh god we'll see
you guys around
i'll be good until the cameras are on be
kind
see you guys later uh thank you all and
uh
thanks for watching see you later bye